la fermeture du rhône à de saint lambert
c'est aussi la disparition d'une
véritable institution chère au coeur des
résidents du secteur
c'est l'envié de passer des plus grands
cour à bois de la région
il y avait ici des matériaux qu'on
retrouve par ailleurs jeux d'embouts
physique on a ferme c'est donc tu
magasins locaux qui ferme à notre
détriment
à carignan où le rona a ouvert ses
portes il y a deux ans à peine
les employés ont le moral en berne les
gens sont tristes matin il ya eu
quelques larmes qui se sont versés
erreur puis ce matin aussi c'est de
saint sauveur ne se porte guère mieux
des emplois ici d'une vingtaine
trentaine d'années de service qui ont
servi avec leur coeur pile de ce fait
dix à la dernière minute
c'est très dur et pas aux 34 magasins
ferment leurs portes partout au pays
au québec mais également en ontario en
alberta en nouvelle écosse en
colombie-britannique en saskatchewan
au québec on recense 12 fermetures dans
douze localités à granby bécancour sorel
trois-rivières carignan notamment en
dévoilant ses résultats financiers la
direction de lausanne a invoqué des
chiffres inférieurs aux attentes pour
justifier la fermeture de 34 magasins au
rendement insuffisant
l'association de la quincaillerie abonde
dans ce sens ils ne sont pas sous
performants ils sont carrément
déficitaires alors peut-être que c'est
un ménage qui a tardé à être fait qui
devait être fait et il a sa tombe sous
cette administration il ne semble pas
que l'arrivée de l'eau a permis à l'oser
donc en mode réductions de coûts
l'entreprise veut également réduire ses
effectifs corporatif procéder à une
réorganisation administrative et
simplifier ses enseignes
au canada les difficultés de lauzes
pourrait avantager ses concurrents et on
voit l'émergence de concurrents de
concurrents régionaux bon patrick morin
bmr kanak est accompagné pour l'heure
plus de 800 travailleurs vont perdre
leur emploi
un nombre qui pourrait être plus élevé
puisque certains analystes croient que
la vague de fermeture
est loin d'être terminé et si maxime
bertrand radio canada montréal